quel a été l'effet économique et social
de la crise sanitaire dans les
différents territoires français et
comment y répondre le député modem des
yvelines jean noël barrot a longuement
enquêté et publie un rapport très
concret parfois surprenant quand on lit
en détails quelles zones
particulièrement touchées
quels effets de la crise sur le marché
immobilier comment bien cibler les aides
pour qu'elle soit efficace
au-delà du constat le rapport contient
une trentaine de propositions très
concrètes
alors vous êtes chef d'entreprise
salariés particulier qui a choisi
pourquoi pas déménagé depuis la crise
nous attendons vos questions et
témoignages pour dialoguer avec notre
invité
01 45 24 7 milles et l'appli france
inter rubrique réagir bonjour jean noël
barrot bonjour premier constat dans
votre rapport les zones les plus
affectées par la crise je cite le top 3
la tarentaise en savoie roissy saint
louis en alsace vire en normandie
thouars dans les deux sèvres j'en ai
cité 5
ce ne sont pas forcément les zones qui
étaient en difficulté auparavant
pourquoi cela absolument c'est une des
surprises qui a été celle de l'analyse
que nous avons conduite d'abord en nous
déplaçant dans chacune des 13 régions de
france métropolitaine et en mobilisant
énormément de données assez inédite pour
mesurer les effets de la crise est ce
qui ressort c'est une dimension
territoriale très forte
beaucoup de différences entre les
territoires et puis des effets
inattendus
effectivement la géographie de la crise
de la baisse d'activité ne recouvre pas
la géographie des fragilités
préexistantes la géographie des gilets
jaunes et vous avez dans le top-35 que
vous venez de citer des zones qui
étaient prospères avant la crise c'est
le cas de la tarentaise oui bien sûr ça
va aider et des zones qui étaient
beaucoup plus fragiles c'est le cas de
roissy par exemple et alors qu'est ce
qui s'est passé dans ces zones eh bien
écoutez là l'activité a baissé en marty
pour la montagne en raison de tourisme
tourisme à roissy c'est l'activité
aéronautique mais ce qu'on constate
c'est aussi que beaucoup d'entreprises
qui sont pas directement impactés par la
crise parce qu'elles n'ont pas fermé
administrativement par exemple ont
malgré tout su une baisse d'activité
parce qu'elle était à proximité soit
deux centres urbains avec du télétravail
de l'activité partielle soit à proximité
d'entreprises aéronautiques avec donc
une baisse des services aux entreprises
il faut pas regarder que par secteur il
faut regarder localement par micro
région si j'ose dire absolument vous
pouvez être une entreprise donnée avec
dans une un secteur donné à voir une
activité complètement différente pour
les douze mois de crise
selon vous est situé à roissy une soit
vous êtes située dans le maine et loire
autre phénomène à la rubrique constat on
va parler pâtisserie un peu l'effet
donuts
alors là il s'agit d'aider déménagement
possible amorce d'exode urbain dit vous
les mots sont forts mais vous êtes
prudent possible amorce d exode urbain
c'est l'idée que beaucoup de gens ont
quitté les le coeur des métropoles pour
aller en périphérie et même en grande
périphérie normandie loiret pour les
parisiens isère où un pour les lyonnais
la logique est la même à marseille et
toulouse
je donne un chiffre second semestre 2010
9 second semestre 2020 la comparaison
aux des acquisitions de biens
immobiliers dans un autre département +
13 % absolument + 13 % et quand on
s'intéresse à paris par exemple il avait
cité le lyon ou marseille on pourrait
parler de toulouse et de nantes là même
le même phénomène se produit on voit une
augmentation de plus de 150% vers leur
on voit de ce même augmentation de plus
de 150% vers le loiret et al'inverse on
voit évidemment les la la la les
acquisitions de maisons diminué en
petite couronne parisienne et dans les
destinations de résidences secondaires
comme la corse et c est donc vraiment
sont des gens qui ont acquis des maisons
dans la périphérie dans les départements
périphériques plus ruraux moins denses
et c'est une accélération très forte
d'un phénomène que l'on pressentait déjà
un petit peu ce se produire mais qui la
modifie profondément les dynamiques et
les équipes territoriaux rééquilibrage
comment est-ce qu'on peut l'encourager
pour qu'il soit durable et que ce
rééquilibrage entre métropole et reste
du territoire se se se confirme encore
évidemment il pose ce rééquilibrage un
certain nombre de questions puisque si
vous avez des familles qui se déplace à
l'extérieur des grandes métropoles va se
poser un certain nombre de questions de
service public par exemple mais il y à
des situations pour lesquelles se ferait
qu' libre âge est très positif je vous
cite le cas de l'ariège où nous nous
sommes rendus qui est tout près de
toulouse et où s'organise un pack
télétravail pour attirer des salariés de
la métropole toulousaine vers la ville
de pamiers qui est une ville de 20 mille
habitants dont le centre s'est dépeuplée
au fil des années qui étend des prises
et qui va donc pouvoir accueillir ces
populations de l'agglomération
toulousaine leur offrir un cadre de vie
meilleur en leur proposant un logement
en proposant des solutions de garde
d'enfants en proposant un emploi pour le
conjoint
ça le pack télétravail c'est des mesures
très concrètes pour encourager au
télétravail alors à mi-chemin du constat
des propositions vous dites que les
dispositifs dette par zones définies
depuis paris pour le dire de manière
caricaturale les quartiers prioritaires
de la ville les zones de revitalisation
rurale ça marche pas le maillage est
trop large et puis en fait alors ça
c'est un point intéressant on en fait
beaucoup sur des incitations fiscales
qui ne marche pas tellement non plus
pour aller s'installer dans ces zones là
oui alors là on prend un petit peu de
recul et me dit qu'elle a été la
doctrine d'intervention de l'état face
aux risques de décrochage des
territoires bien pendant des décennies
ça a été une logique passive on a des
zonages économiques dans lesquelles
certains entreprises peuvent bénéficier
d'exonérations et le bilan de tout cela
c'est que ça n'a pas très bien
fonctionné depuis quelques années l'état
a changé son approche en prenant une
approche plus ascendante un peu plus
bottom up
on va là on part du terrain on part du
terrain ont créé des labels et charges
au terrain charge aux territoires de se
coordonner de se donner un constat
partagé une vision d'avenir pour le
territoire et là on va chercher le label
et on mobilise toutes les énergies
autour de cela dont je reviens sur les
incitations fiscales il ya un point
intéressant dans le rapport comment
attirer de jeunes médecins dans les
territoires est typiquement on met en
place des incitations fiscales vous
paierez moins cher l'installation de
votre cabinet etc
ça marche pas tellement ce qu'ils
veulent c'est de l'emploi et des
services publics de l'emploi pour la
famille et des services publics pour la
famille là aussi dans le territoire où
il s'installe oui c'est tout à fait vrai
en tout cas c'est ce que c'est ce qu'ont
montré les études qui sont intéressés à
ces zonages et donc pour résorber les
déserts médicaux il faut trouver
d'autres solutions
alors les solutions concrètes vous
parliez de ce pack télétravail parlez
nous du prêt de main d'oeuvre qui a
marché par exemple en lot-et-garonne
oui alors nous ce qu'on dit c'est que
les solutions elles viendront des
territoires pourquoi parce que ils ont à
la faveur si je puis dire de la crise
repris leur destin en main nous on a
vraiment senti sur les territoires un
vent de renaissance et que l'état doit
accompagner cela est donc ce que nous
disons c'est que pour la sortie de crise
il faut une stratégie coopérer
territorialisée régénérer et le coopérer
c'est ce que vous dites c'est le prêt de
main d'oeuvre avec des exemples
extraordinaire sur le terrain on était
emmené en lot-et-garonne où des salariés
techniciens de l'aéronautique ont été
mis à disposition par une entreprise qui
était quasi à l'arrêt
chez le numéro deux de la confiture que
vous connaissez sans doute lucien
georgelin et ses techniciens vont aider
lucien georgelin optimiser ses circuits
de production
le prêt de main d'oeuvre a émergé
pendant la crise le gouvernement en a
facilité les modalités est ce que nous
proposons c'est d'aller encore plus loin
de pérenniser les arts et les
assouplissements et de faciliter la
diffusion de ce dispositif
assouplissement par exemple le cumul est
un cdd le chômage partiel dans le cadre
d'un prêt de main d'oeuvre ça peut être
quelque chose de ce cumul est l'activité
partielle de longue durée avec du prêt
demain doivent ya beaucoup d'entreprises
aujourd'hui qui cherche désespérément de
la main d'oeuvre et notamment de la main
d'oeuvre qualifiée
il faut que les entreprises qui sont en
baisse d'activité parce que leur secteur
et particulièrement touchées puissent
bénéficier de l'activité partielle de
longue durée pour préserver leurs
compétences mais tout en prêtant mettant
à disposition leurs salariés aux
entreprises qui en ont besoin
la désindustrialisation pourquoi jean
noël barrot la lombardie s'en sort mieux
que certaines régions françaises
ben écoutez il ya déjà dédé des raisons
évidemment multiples nous ce que nous
disons c'est que à l'avenir et au delà
de toutes les mesures que nous proposons
pour la sortie de crise je les dis c'est
là la coopération entre les acteurs de
terrain qui s'est beaucoup développé
c'est vraiment autour d'un l'idée d'un
d'un capital relationnel d'un capital
territoriale entre tous les acteurs
qu'il faut évidemment faire fructifier
territorialisée pour donner plus de
levier à l'état sur les territoires et
puis régénérer en libérant les énergies
mais au delà de la crise il faut que
nous puissions a minima nous doter d'un
instrument puissant qui unifie qui
concentre les leviers d'intervention de
l'état en direction des territoires qui
sont menacés de décrochage de manière
active de manière bottom up ascendante
de manière responsabilisante pour les
acteurs de terrain et pour éviter ce
qu'on a vu pendant des décennies c'est à
dire des territoires qui décroche avec
conséquences économiques conséquences
sociales et puis à terme les
conséquences politiques qu'on a vu
pendant le mouvement des vies les choses
je reviens sur ma question sur la
lombarde il n'y avait pas répondu qu'est
ce qui se passe en lombardie un tissu de
pme très important très dense la
désindustrialisation en france dans le
nord et l'est en particulier ça souvent
été le fait de grandes entreprises donc
ce que vous dites c'est que si on
encourage les petites entreprises sur
place
voilà il ya un moyen d'enrayer cette dé
tout à fait
raison et vous avez fait une meilleure
réponse que je ne l'aurais fait à votre
question
ce qui est certain c'est que
effectivement en italie à une culture en
lombardie d'alliance entre les
entreprises pour les que pour aller
chercher l'export pour aller chercher
les appels d'offres européens
jusqu'à présent on s'était dit en france
ça ne marchera pas parce qu'il ya pas
suffisamment de liens ya pas
suffisamment de liens entre les
entreprises
ce que nous disons nous dans ce rapport
c'est que désormais ces relations
existent parce que pendant la crise les
entreprises se sont serré les coudes et
que des liens se sont noués entre elles
et que c'est donc peut-être le moment
d'essayer d'adopter ce modèle là qui a
fait le succès de la lombardie il faut
aussi vous dites qu'il faut partir du
terrain c'est pas toujours facile de par
exemple de défendre ou de mener à bien
un projet dans le cadre du plan de
relance de défendre un dossier
vous dites qu'il faut qu'ils aient des
gens dans les territoires j'imagine
d'aider des fonctionnaires qu'ils soient
là pour aider piloter accompagner les
entrepreneurs dans ben voilà dans dans
la défense de ses de ses projets de
qu'ils ont pour leur entreprise
absolument que ce soit des entreprises
ou des collectivités c'est vrai que
quand on est un peu plus petit c'est
toujours plus compliqué est bien de
déposer des dossiers de candidature à
tous ses appels à projets de les
identifier que dans le jargon
administratif on appelle ça l'ingénierie
c'est à dire en gros le montage de
dossiers et nous ce que nous disons
c'est d'abord il faut il faut rendre
l'accès à cette aide au montage de
dossiers à cet accompagnement plus
simple et donc on propose la création
d'un site de rencontre entre l'offre et
la demande a généré on appelle ça
ingénierie point gouv.fr c'est un chef
d'entreprise une collectivité une petite
collectivité une petite commune peu et
bien tout simplement ligne trouver
toutes les facilités qui existent
aujourd'hui pour beaucoup qui ont été
développés dans les mois récents
mais qui sont difficiles à trouver ce
qu'on sait pas forcément où aller
chercher
et puis on propose effectivement
d'envoyer un certain nombre de hauts
fonctionnaires sur le terrain pour aider
ces collectivités
ces entreprises à monter les dossiers on
a vu d'ailleurs une des exemples
intéressants comme en moselle où les
acteurs locaux ont créé les développeurs
de france roland c'est à dire une
quarantaine de personnes qui vont au
contact des entreprises pour les aider à
monter les dossiers ou encore à vierzon
dans le cher où le préfet a pris 10
service civique
les envoie dans les collectivités pour
là aussi les aider à identifier les bons
appels à projets pour la relance et le
rebond
je reviens sur les pme vous dit une
chose pour les pour les encourager
choses forcément polémique il faut
encore assouplir le droit du travail ces
entreprises là en ont besoin de votre
point de vue vous voyez la controverse
que ça peut susciter
oui alors ce que nous disons c'est c'est
de le régénérer un le troisième pilier
du triptyque c'est qu'il faut évidemment
rien s'interdire pour que dans les
territoires fragiles et bien les jeunes
entreprises puissent émerger il est
possible aujourd'hui par la voie de la
négociation syndicale de permettre
certaines dérogations aux jeunes
entreprises donc nous ce que nous disons
dans le rapport c'est qu'il faut que les
partenaires sociaux puissent essayer de
se saisir de cela pour que dans les
territoires fragiles et pour les jeunes
entreprises quelques dérogations puisse
être donnée encore un mot là aussi c'est
un enseignement de la période
l'enseignement à distance s'est
développée dans les universités dans le
supérieur
il ya une importance grande de
l'enseignement supérieur dans les
territoires à proximité et vous dites il
faut mettre en place d'aidés des campus
où on développerait un enseignement
hybride à moitié en présentiel à moitié
à distance
oui là où le rapport trans peut-être
avec ses prédécesseurs c'est qui dit il
faut traiter cette question des
compétences dans les territoires
fragiles pour des raisons économiques
parce qu'il faut trouver des compétences
pour les entreprises mais pour des
raisons aussi d'équité et de lutte
contre les inégalités parce que s'il ya
bien une inégalité qui est très
importante en france
et bien c'est que le département où on
et conditionne votre accès à
l'enseignement supérieur est donc là où
notre proposition tranche c'est que nous
disions il faut rapprocher
l'enseignement supérieur et la formation
professionnelle des territoires qui n'en
disposent pas avec effectivement des
campus hybride avec des mobilités ou des
facilités donné à la mobilité des
enseignants chercheurs
nous l'avons vu à vierzon un campus
urbain va s'installer sur une friche
industrielle qui était là depuis 25 ans
qui était inoccupé en plein centre ville
nous l'avons vu à foix en ariège où une
unité de l'université de de toulouse
s'est installée et en 96 en 2016 pardon
a créé la première licence
pluridisciplinaire et c'était la seule
option d'accès à l'enseignement
supérieur pour les jeunes ariégeois et
donc nous disons dans les territoires
fragiles et fragilisé
il faut imaginer des initiatives de ce
type là je voudrais garder une minute
vous n'êtes pas venu pour ça mais pour
parler d'abstention parce que vous êtes
le coauteur d'un livre blanc sur
l'abstention qui est un sujet diablement
d'actualité au détour de ce rapport
vous dites qu'une mesure du mal être
dans les territoires relégué bien c'est
l'abstention il ya un lien robuste avec
l'évolution du taux d'emploi avec la
fermeture d'un commerce élémentaire
l'abstention voilà suit tout cela
directement une mesure pour lutter
contre l'abstention
ce serait laquelle de votre point de vue
jean noël barrot à l'abstention allait
elle a des causes multiples et c'est
lorsqu'on a dit dans le dans le livre
blanc il ya évidemment tout ce qui peut
faciliter l'accès vote donc le vote à
distance l'inscription sur liste
électorale
aujourd'hui 9 millions de français ne
sont pas inscrits dans la commune où ils
résident et ces français là ça tienne
beaucoup plus que les autres
il ya évidemment une réforme
institutionnelle qui est qui qui semble
indispensable
nous vous défendre au modem avec
françois bayrou le principe de la
proportionnelle mais vous avez raison il
ya aussi toutes les réformes et toute la
manière dont nous pouvons traiter de ce
déclin industriel qui est le grand
oublié des politiques publiques des
décennies passées
si nous traitons ce sujet alors sans
doute nous rapprocheront les citoyens
des urnes
merci jean noël barrot d'être venu dans
les studios de france inter et on trouve
facilement ce rapport sur un terrain